No more loops.
We're fine now.
Sorry, I was trying to find a clipboard.
Then I got... I ran out of time to Photoshop it.
So I'm not a very good Amazon worker, apparently.
What do Amazon warehouse workers even wear?
Warehouse workers.
Yeah!
Oh, I gotta get...
Oh, wait, I gotta grab...
I gotta grab an orange vest.
Give me a sec.
I gotta be immersive, guys.
Orange vest.
PNG.
Guys, we gotta be immersive.
Okay?
It's all about the immersion.
I want you to feel.
I want you to feel the depression.
I...
I've heard a lot of horror stories working at Amazon
warehouses.
And I want you guys to feel like immersed.
Oh yeah.
I want you to feel the sadness and...
depression working in the Amazon warehouse.
Thank you, Doki.
You guys are like, I come to watch you to escape reality,
not bring me back.
Doki, no, I work at Amazon.
Doki, no, DOL.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The one time I don't want to be embarrassed for no reason.
I hope there's a part in a game where you find a person in
the wrong place and have to find where I'm supposed to work.
No reason to say thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
As a fellow warehouse worker, UPS though, not Amazon.
I honestly, like, is there really a difference?
Is there?
Oh yeah.
And I will promise you guys, I will not go to the bathroom
throughout this stream.
At least I'm unionized.
I welcome Doki to the world of the only fulfilling parcel
work.
Thank you to the super chat.
normal size.
Thank you.
Hmm.
Actual challenge.
Let's go.
If I go to the bathroom, you can deduct my pay, guys.
Alright, let me grab.
I need to grab a transparent orange vest.
Okay, I got it.
Okay, I gotta actually Photoshop this a little bit.
Is this orange vest orange enough?
Wait, is it an orange vest or is it yellow?
Okay, it's either.
I see orange vest more than yellow vest, so I'll go with
that.
Alright.
Let me save this file okay that's you know i was like oh
it's because i didn't want photoshop but like this guy the
vest stays on the we need the orange vest it's practically a
mandatory uniform um it's the orange vest oh shit sir i am a
new worker though orange for new worker i mean that's
perfect i am a new worker let's go it's still real you guys
can be my jeff bezos all right let's see uh amigo edit this
real quick guys it'll be so worth it guys i swear to god
okay i gotta remove i gotta remove this part though the part
the the triangle part so i could put my neck in it uh okay
uh oh shit i deleted everything accidentally okay that's too
much tolerance over here all right and then oh fuck okay i
might have to i might have to do the Magnetic.
Okay.
Magnetic.
I'll do some Photoshop magic right now.
Wait, did I not have the magnetic one?
Okay, there's the... Oh, there you go.
Okay, magnetic lasso tool.
Alright, I'm doing some Photoshop magic right now.
Don't worry, it'll be so worth it, guys.
Oh, God, where is it?
Okay.
There you go.
Alright, and then...
Whoopsie.
Don't worry about it.
Thank you.
Why did you say, whoopsie?
Don't worry about it.
I'm doing some Photoshop magic right now.
Don't, guys, guys, it's going to be so fucking immersive.
You're going to be like, whoa, which Amazon warehouse are
you in right now?
All right.
Let's see.
Okay.
Save.
All right.
I got the save in.
Oh, wait.
Why is it the web P?
Okay.
Wait.
I don't like that.
No web P's here.
All right.
And then put it in.
the streaming assets items and then amazon that's the file
all right all right watch i'm gonna do a little magic trick
real quick for you guys oh yeah okay let's see uh amazon
amazon there you go okay wait this works too well wait a
minute This actually works a little too well.
It was like, there is one thing that we need to do.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
Are you ready?
Okay.
I'm ready to not be in a union right now.
I'm ready to go.
for my no bathroom breaks and zero union.
Let's go, Jeff Bezos.
It's too real.
No, no, no.
Okay, I got my orange vest.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Dokey.
I'm new here.
And I'm ready to make Jeff Bezos another $5 billion.
Let's go.
CEO, entrepreneur, born in 1964, Jeffree.
Jeffrey Bezos, CEO, entrepreneur, born in 1964, Jeffrey,
Jeffrey Bezos.
That's our national anthem whenever we clock in at the
warehouse.
Only $5 billion.
How dare you?
Jeffrey is going to be so disappointed.
I'm sorry, Jeffrey.
I'm sorry.
$1 billion short.
I'm so sad.
To boost morale.
You sound too happy.
It's my first day.
The light is still in my eyes.
It's just my first day, guys.
Don't worry.
They'll squash the fire in my eyes very soon.
Yeah, we need to come on Christmas Day.
We're shorthanded.
All right, here we go.
You think he's actually going to be at our warehouse, guys?
Oh, my God.
I can't wait to see Jeffrey at our warehouse.
All right, let's see.
At my particular warehouse.
All right.
Sound guy.
I don't know if you're alive.
Sinica, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
She still has hope.
Get her.
All right.
At least they did most.
Okay.
You know what?
I got to have at least 180 frames.
I got to make sure I sort the parcels correctly, guys.
Guys, I gotta make sure.
Alright, I mean, I feel like the sensitivity is fine.
Alright, here we go.
Apparently this game is very addicting.
From what I saw in chat.
Not the reviews, but from people in chat that were talking
about it.
Alright, here we go.
It's my first day at work.
Let's go.
Whoa.
I live in the storage department.
It's not sad at all.
Gotta make enough for it.
guys I gotta buy myself a Christmas gift let's go oh oh okay
this is a little bit more depressing now oh okay now wow
Jeff Bezos is oh my Jeff Bezos is such a great boss guys he
got like oh my if you work for Jeffrey Bezos it comes with
one it comes with accommodations oh my god and it's so And
we have an office cat, guys.
Don't look, look, if you work at the Amazon warehouse, you
get affordable housing.
It's great.
Jeff is my landlord.
I can pick it up.
Oh my God, I can redecorate.
Let's put the snowman next to it.
I gotta make it more festive, you know.
Ho, ho, ho.
Office cat is so cold.
Please, please put it inside.
look if the cat wants to go out inside it'll go inside guys
let the cat do what the cat wants all right open all right
yeah guys this is like look it's such a great location too
we're literally next to the city guys oh my god mr bezos is
such a good boss i'm so fortunate to have a boss just like
mr bezos uh Check out relevant criteria.
Oh, how do I do this?
Interact.
I'm focusing.
Oh, they want me to hide it for some reason.
I hit it.
Alright.
It's okay.
They haven't clocked it out.
Ooh, print.
Whoa, what's that?
What is that?
How did I zoom in?
I'm trying to.
It won't let me zoom in.
zoom i know it says dokey it says this to zoom in and i'm
trying i swear to god i want to see my thing oh my god oh my
god please don't fire me mr bezos oh it's approved okay guys
i got it it's approved now oh my god it's my email i have
anything accepted cargo what the fuck when did all these
countries popped up gotta watch the news more guys i gotta
oh my god i gotta watch the more I guess no no okay wait
wait I can't be I can't be buying any of these oh pocket
yeah by a basketball though okay I'm gonna buy that though
check up please this is important I gotta be able to shoot
some hoops at the warehouse we had new countries dropped in
in the latest expansion all right okay all right there you
go all right there you go you have to read the first oh okay
now email oh my god boss man at parcel.co um oh my god and
the basketball will come like straight away too that's the
best part because like we literally live in the warehouse i
used to wear hazmat suit for an engineering company i wore
normal clothing for two part-time jobs for warehouse
companies it's nothing special zyko thank you super chat
thank you thank you all right um boss man the thrilled to
have you on cardboard.
Your mission to choose except, spoiler you did, is to ensure
every parcel gets the red carpet treatment.
Here's a typical day in the warehouse.
Pick a parcel from the delivery door.
Inspect parcel labels for issue.
Attach an approval denial inspection sticker to the parcel.
Finally submit them at either the export door for valid
parcel or the return shoot for invalid parcel.
Fetch parcels from the delivery door at the far side of the
warehouse and inspect them at this inspection table.
Then submit them as valid or invalid based on the set of
ever-changing criteria.
Go to the sidebar to discover your criteria.
Okay, I got this.
I gotta go...
Wait, actually.
Go to the sidebar.
Where the...
The sidebar?
Okay.
That's the statistics.
Where the...
Okay, we can...
Give me a sec.
What?
Where's the criteria?
Guys, give me a sec.
Go to the, on this.
Oh, the sidebar.
I didn't read the tablet.
I was just like, you mean in the room?
Guys, it's just my first day, guys.
It's my first day.
I'm really nervous, okay?
I'm very nervous.
Okay, have one of the following.
valid cargo types in the top left of the label okay uh set
aside until okay today is monday road rail air and maritime
okay i got this oh oh shit okay uh why are they made up okay
if they were like if they gave us real countries this would
be a lot easier dokey i'll dare you they just announced
today.
They just declared independence today, How fucking dare you?
Okay.
We got this.
Alright.
We can do this.
Hi.
Why does it want me to hide my fucking thing?
Open the delivery door.
Alright.
I opened it.
Oh, okay.
Pick up the parcel.
Check parcels have a valid country name and flag.
Cargo type in the top left corner.
Oh my gosh.
I mean, I could be role-playing as Canada post right now,
but we're still on strike.
This is good.
Amazon warehouse is the closest I can get.
Alright.
Oh, I remember this.
Okay, yeah.
We got...
this this is good and then print all right we got print we
got print okay i'm gonna print this closer to me all right
print approval and then we gotta grab this boom yeah they
got back on strike yeah yeah guys are like we had thought
this no they got it was like it wasn't like uh they didn't
the strike technically never ended it was like a ceasefire
uh it was a ceasefire until the new government came in and
then yeah and then they went back on strike yeah it was like
season two it was like you know during a christmas holiday
during the world war ii they had a little ceasefire for
christmas um so they did that and they went back on yeah
they just took a little yes to break and came back on
strike.
So, like...
Alright.
Approve you the valid submission.
Yay!
Okay, I did that.
Press the...
I have to press the... Oh, there you go.
Submit.
Take that parcel.
Or was it... Oh, it was World War I.
Alright, I meant World War I.
Alright.
People got a little less whimsy.
When two came along.
Alright, history lessons.
Yeah!
Okay.
Check the country and cargo type.
Oh, wait, we got another one.
Oh, I guess this is the invalid one.
I wonder why.
We don't need to talk about it.
Stren Tom.
The fuck?
Okay.
Oh, they don't have them.
Wait, they don't have the delivery thing.
Wait, was it?
Okay, Stren...
Okay, Stren Tom is a state place, but they don't have the...
Okay, they don't...
I don't know how to deliver this, bro.
How the fuck are we gonna deliver this?
Alright.
Hello, let me interact.
Denial!
Someone ain't getting their present on Christmas.
Sorry, bro.
We gotta put denial.
I'll stick it on here and throw it away and then sell.
Oh my god, you know what's fucked up?
You know, like, there's like, uh, also I don't know if Sound
Guy was ever was alive today.
Uh, so I don't know if the sound's been okay.
But do you know, like, there's like, uh, they're not
scalpers, but when the parcels are invalid, they, uh, they
auctioned the stuff off for people and people like lined up
in like, uh, hundreds to like try and grab like, they're
like little mini mystery boxes and they try uh to see if
they can like scalp it off that's crazy all right tonight i
want to go it's like somebody's like and i remember what i
don't remember whose video was but like this guy was like
wanted to try it out like a little loopback like a little
loopbox slash mystery box and like one of the packages was a
was a dog's ashes and i was like holy oh my god this poor
guy has package What's this fucking dog's ashes?
And this guy fucking...
Yeah, the guy opened the box and it was literally like...
They're like reading...
They're like, what is this?
And they were reading like the...
The pamphlet.
And he's like, oh my god, they're fucking ashes.
Imagine losing your dog's ashes!
At the...
Like at the fucking UPS.
That shit's crazy.
Okay.
Um, I think he tried to, I remember reading that he tried to
return it.
Okay, Jonathania.
Jeez, how am I going to remember all these made-up fucking
countries?
Okay, Jonathania actually- Okay, Jonathania exists.
Okay, I was going to say.
Oh, wait, it already hasn't approved.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, I don't have to- I don't have to approve these.
You got your real.
All right, here you go.
You're a real country.
Let's go.
Cass, Cass, thank you for the magenta soup, thank you, thank
you.
Hey, Doki, are you enjoying the waging cage life?
It's been a bit, but can I get belated?
Happy birthday?
Can you also tell me I'm pretty cool?
You're pretty cool, Cass.
And also, happy belated birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Cass.
Yeah, happy birthday!
all right all right let's see where are you call oh i just i
just had a package in jonathia newly made country even oh
okay oh my god i can open the tab okay you should have told
me that in the first place what the fuck you mean i'm my own
personal tablet oh mr bezos you're so kind okay industrial
skills shop on your Oh my god, he gave me my own personal
tablet, but I do have to buy my own skills, though.
Alright, check out.
Oh wait, where's the current delivery truck?
Oh, it's here.
Oh my god, my basketball is here, guys.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Alright, let's see.
How do I open it?
Oh, cute.
Oh my god, let's fucking go!
I just need to...
Guys, if I work hard enough, I'll be able to afford...
I'll be able to afford a basketball hoop.
Let's go, I can go.
Alright, check out.
You know, you know, it's part of the process.
I...
I use my pay to buy stuff for work, and then I'll get
reimbursed, right?
Yeah?
Mr. Bezos will reimburse me for this.
guys.
He's definitely going to reimburse me, guys.
right?
Yeah, it's not like the rush gets richer.
Surely he'll reimburse me for a job well done.
Alright.
Open and place the scales?
Let's see.
What's this?
Alright, on a delay.
okay uh open and place this yes all right share whoa okay
maybe this was not the best place to put okay i was gonna
say i think i want uh a weight class oh my god wait a weight
class okay give me a sec all right we'll we'll put it
actually let's put this let's put this like right here i
feel like that's okay yeah like and make sure that i face me
wait how the do i okay i just put oh yeah there you go all
right okay by train pru pruania all right is that it's
pruania part of the eligible countries that i can ship to
submit in bat nice work you're getting ready you know you
can submit oh yeah be careful though okay it's all right is
he oh pruia Oh, you're real.
Wait, is that the right flag?
Rua Nia?
Wait, that's not the right flag.
What the fuck?
How did they get the flag wrong?
Oh, my God.
I... Oh, my God.
I didn't look at the... Oh, no.
I didn't look at the other flags.
I... Oh, no.
Okay, well...
I assume I didn't fuck that up on the other flags.
I think it's fine.
I don't think I fucked it up, guys.
Okay, denial.
Alright, there you go.
No, it should be fine.
I think, I don't think I did.
There's no way.
Surely I made no mistake, guys.
Surely, don't worry.
You're getting your fucking package.
You're getting your Amazon package right before Christmas,
guys.
Look, see?
I got plus $49.
Look.
There's no invalid prices.
Oh, my God.
I'm doing such a great job.
Oh, my.
I'm going to get my Christmas bonus soon.
A basketball hoop.
guys he's gonna give me a basketball hoop guys I can feel it
all right what do I need to get weight class what the fuck
is that oh my god that's it guys I'm getting there okay
maybe I don't think mr.
Bezos is gonna give me a basketball hoop guys I might be a
little out of his budget I understand, Mr. Bezos.
I understand.
You don't have that much money to spare.
Oh, it's in a license department.
Wait, I have to purchase my own license?
Okay, I get it.
I get it, Mr. Bezos.
I see what you're cooking, you know?
If they're a dedicated worker and wish to climb the...
in which to climb the the social ladder like we gotta make
some sacrifices you know we gotta show him our dedication
that we want to work here and we are willing to improve
ourselves for the company i see the vision i gotta invest to
impress exactly if i want to climb the social and corporate
ladder I get it.
Is that a bed?
What the fuck?
Is that a cake?
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
Okay, I gotta put this on the ground.
So I gotta zoom in.
I'm fucking confused.
Yeah, that's a goddamn cake.
Wait a minute.
There's no cake cakes here.
There's no such thing as delivery by cake.
all right let's see it deny all right no I can't afford okay
we're gonna deny this sorry bro we're gonna be selling this
we're gonna be auctioning it off then you're a scalper oh
yeah I should shake it it has a that's a you know it you
know it's a good you know it's a good parcel when it has a
little ribbon on it
got thoroughly shaken and make sure uh make sure everything
is broken a little christmas present from amazon all right
marlin okay let's see that's the right flag
okay by truck all right there you go put that here oh my god
please stop please i do not want to pick Please!
Okay, here you go.
Alright.
I wanted to grab this.
Hello.
Oh, no more piracy.
Oh, no!
I'm too late!
Don't worry.
I can still send one out.
Oh, I forgot.
I forgot.
I'm... I'm time.
Okay, wait.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's just a little slanted now.
You guys don't notice that, right?
Oh my god, okay, wait, I can't use it.
It starts to vibrate.
Remember, don't open them.
All right, we're all...
Okay, we got a clock up now.
I go to sleep.
No overtime.
I'm not allowed to get overtime.
Money spent.
Total minus $75.
Look, I'm investing in myself right now.
all right day two ready for another wonderful day at work
real shell shop purchases here oh okay so if i bought
something i don't need wait where's my one day one day i'll
know what it's like to just throw a basketball into a
basketball hoop all right okay now i can put this in here
Approve for delivery.
Let's go.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Ooh, another Christmas present.
Gotta make sure I drop.
There's no fragile sticker.
I didn't do this as many times as I want.
Yeah, I just need to work for 20 more years and then I'll be
able to afford heat.
Oh, my first pill?
dear electricity we're looming you please check out we send
bills every three day guys it's okay i understand i
understand the vision mr bezos i understand we gotta show
our dedication to the company and you know we gotta think
about the environment if i get billed i'm more conscious
about my surroundings and my environment he's just trying to
make me more aware more culturally and socially aware of the
world you know we gotta fight global warming and It all
starts with me.
The ununionized worker.
Okay, Tuesday.
Road, Rail, Air, Maritime.
Okay.
I see the vision, Mr. Bezos.
I see it.
Okay.
Strandum.
Wait, is that the right?
It's not the right one, is it?
Wait, I gotta...
Okay, it's brown.
How the fuck do you get that incorrect?
Oh, it is brown.
Okay, I gotta make sure.
Alright, truck.
I gotta be able to do this a little bit faster.
Cheerful messages from companies somehow feel worse than the
rude ones would.
And thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
this owners need more dokeys in the world they need more
me's in the world so they can fully embrace capitalism and
take advantage of me what is it called work till i die
okay all right wait that's the right okay and then oh that
should be fine what i'll be faster guys it's just i'm new
okay I'll get faster eventually.
Alright, here you go.
No pain, no gain, exactly.
We're at a company.
Yeah, work until the AI to replace you.
Oh, shit, nice.
That one's already pre-examined by David from across the
Amazon office.
Alright, here you go.
$29.
I'm almost there.
Yay.
Oh, more packages?
Let's go.
Yay.
Hard worker is a good worker.
It's a happy worker, too.
All right.
Strand town.
Oh, my God.
Eventually, I'm going to remember what the flags.
All right.
By train.
Yeah.
Is that the right?
Okay, it is.
I don't know.
It feels like they're going to fuck with me.
Oh, my God.
It's from Nile.co.yard Crime.
is in a box that has crime at the bottom all right i feel
like this is a site right in time for the christmas season
by email this could have been an email all right no it's
already denied this yeah buddy this is not we're not doing
that here we don't do that here maybe i go to ups bro not at
the amazon facility you don't ask questions just your job
the cry box do not drop whoops whoopsie okay vocat vocua
where is that is that a is that real vocua green oh okay
yeah that's real you they're real they're real people
Do we allow mods to unionize?
Who said that?
If my hero doesn't have unions, do you think you're better
than Mr. Bezos?
Do you think you're better than him?
Um, Mr. Bezos is a billionaire's.
And, oh, of course, and if he's a billionaire, that means he
knows what's right.
Right?
Mods will stop it.
all right capitalism's strongest soldier wait what website
is this wave water water sports equipment hired to tick okay
wait south port by carrot okay yeah i was gonna say let's
make check the country first Oh, it sees everything look
good.
And then, bye, Garrett.
Mr. Bezos or Edison?
I think it was Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Well, the thing is, one is still alive.
And he's recently single.
Guys, there is.
Guys, we all have a chance, guys.
We all have a chance.
Oh, that's not the right flag.
than that.
There's hope for all of us.
I see.
Yeah.
His ex-wife got, like, hundreds of billions of dollars, but
she's donating it all to charity.
I don't know what Mr. Basil is doing.
It was like, but I know he's doing a great job.
Alright.
By time.
Okay, what if it is a real?
Okay, I got, I just gotta make sure.
Guys, I had to make sure.
Like, we have offered those services.
You know, maybe it's, like, by time travel or some shit.
I gotta make sure we offer time travel or not.
You don't know that.
Maybe we do.
Maybe we offer time travel.
The time wizard is shipping my package.
Oh, wait, I have enough.
Oh, my God.
I got the weight class now.
Yeah, but if I buy this, it'll make it harder.
But I do...
Oh, I get more.
I get paid more, though.
Alright.
I got weight class now.
I got my license.
Uh, five more parcels.
Uh, Linux.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
That will explain the same.
No, that's just our drones.
Uh, not.
Wait, John Othia?
That's not John Othia.
I would recognize.
Yeah, that's not John Othia.
It must be an easier way to...
Oh, wait, it came in pre- Oh, sorry, I just didn't trust
David from down the hall, you know?
He was hired, like, uh, 10 seconds after me.
And, like, you know, I, clearly I have more experience than
David from down the hall.
All right, let's see.
You made the perfect choice.
All right, here we go.
Oh, it's already came in.
All right, there we go.
Oh, when does my, when does my workday stop?
All right.
Johnathia.
Okay, I remember Johnathia.
I have to look just to be... Okay, there you go.
Alright.
Approve.
There you go.
And then we put that.
And then Workday got clocked up for work.
Alright, submit.
Submit.
He doesn't offer overtime, which makes sense, you know?
Makes sense.
Why do we need overtime?
We get paid just enough money like once a week.
Investigate the contracts room.
Oh my god, I get contracts now?
You trust me that much?
Go, thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki has my birthday kit come through your warehouse.
My 29th birthday is in four days.
And I'm worried it won't arrive in time, please.
My birthday really is in four days.
Go, thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, no problem.
Don't worry.
It's gonna get there in time, sir.
what it looks like and like if you have any fragile fragile
items in there just just just give me the relevant
information especially like how fragile are the items in
your package uh oh zero thank you super chat thank you thank
you thank you face is gonna be one a new target for this
chinese get rich quick hustling courses thank you a super
chat thank you thank you oh my god i was just reminded of
the tick tock of this guy that was giving like how to say
how to say how can i get big booty big uh what was it big
booty latina baddies uh in the area but in chinese did
anyone see that tweet i was like what the it's like it's
like just how you can say it in chinese and he's like um
wait i don't know what did the opportunity arrive where
you're looking for big booty baddie latinas in the area you
know you gotta know what if it somehow comes up you gotta be
prepared my name is boy how i don't just don't remember let
me see i can find it um okay
chinese baddie latina Yes, I am searching that right now.
I didn't book.
Unfortunately, I did not book.
I wish I did.
I wish that was what I bookmarked.
But I forgot to bookmark that for specific video.
Unfortunate, guys.
Don't keep don't.
It's vital.
It's what?
Okay, you got to be prepared for any occasion, guys, in any
language.
You accept contracts to income needs to earn additional
income.
ourselves for a contract and submit them via this room okay
oh that promotion sir oh in a contracts tab okay boss man
training okay oh my god 250 i can almost pay rent okay uh to
complete oh just any two oh yeah i'll activate that two is
fine press and load oh it's time all right let's go we're
ready for another oh oh i have to go sleep oh sorry mr
baseless i forgot no overtime you're right you're right just
make enough for the day almost can't afford to live let's go
plus eight dollars let's go we don't need savings we just
live check by check just like how he wanted to perfect
capitalist employees uh my name thank you for super chat
thank you thank you this game needs a usa difficulty where
you start with negative two thousand dollars because you're
saving up for dental surgery i was thinking of a super chat
thank you thank green is green exactly green is green this
is not funny this is how we live
All right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How realistic is this game?
Do they have?
Do they have Peabody's Merry Christmas?
Don't worry.
I'm trying to immerse myself by giving me no bathroom breaks
throughout the stream.
All right.
Another, another day, another, not even another, another
scent.
Oh shit, we have weight class now.
I forgot.
Start weighing parcels.
Good work picking up.
license nice to finally have an employee that wants to do
more with no problem mr boss man
all right let's see from next you'll need to weigh parcels
and check their weight go to the weight oh my god okay zero
to 15 all right i don't uh all right is this okay 14 okay
you're just correct oh my god then i have to make sure if
your country is real okay your country is real okay that's
good all right that's good print approval you live in a real
place you live in an area where i can do deliveries oh my
god okay this way all right yeah dude more underpaid work mr
pesos oh my god thank you sir all right d What did I do to
serve such a great boss?
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Fuck.
Um.
Okay, that's fine.
Sorry.
I don't want to align it anymore.
All right.
What country is this?
My teen.
Wait, is this my cake?
Oh, my God.
I didn't even need to weigh this.
It was delivered by cake.
Wait.
Do we offer that yet?
Okay, we don't.
I just got...
I don't know.
Maybe.
Maybe it's someone sending this package to the prisons, you
know?
And there's like a fucking, there's like, um, there's like,
what are they called?
Those, those, those things that cut bars.
What if they're sending it to a prison?
I don't know.
It's got to be sure we offer the services.
Our new prison service.
Yeah, a file.
What if they're sending a file to the local jail?
It's like a prison break situation.
all right let's send that up yeah better safe than sorry all
right i gotta make sure they're real first before wait why
is it by box do we do that no okay we don't i see it do we
send it to another i don't know for box like we sent it to
another delivery company like from amazon to ups oh yeah i'd
be double shirt all right got that down okay we got denied
here thanks david and i got paid for your work too that's
the best part all right okay congrati i remember what that
that country looks like okay yeah and then d all right and
then the weight is zero to 20 kg Oh, wrong way, class, sir.
I'm sorry.
We're going to have to give it to the scalpers now.
Sorry, buddy.
I don't care if this is an urn of your dead grandma.
You forgot to put on the sticker, bro.
You're talking to...
You got a file of complaint in our AI.
In our iPhone AIs.
I fucking hate that now.
Everyone uses the AI phones.
Like the AI, like, call sheet.
Okay.
All right.
Which one?
No!
Oh, okay, it's good.
Okay, okay.
First time.
This is my first mistake, guys.
Oh, no.
They marked me.
I'm sorry.
I thought her granny wasn't real.
They literally announced independence like five, like five
minutes ago.
Not terminally online.
Mr. Bezos.
All I've been doing is just working in this, in this sorting
facility.
Okay, 13.
Wait, 13.56.
Yeah, that's a C.
Right?
I got, I'm going to read, I'm going to read scale this.
I got to make sure.
The C says a B, but like, okay, 13.
Yeah.
And I got to be sure.
I gotta be sure.
I already have one strike.
Denial.
I can't believe Doki lost my order.
No, no, it's not my fault.
It's not my fault.
You guys, your country announced independence five minutes
ago.
I didn't know.
I gotta make sure.
I'm gonna submit this.
I'm paranoid now.
Okay, I got the right one.
Yeah, there's no time to learn new geography.
Okay, Yadda, Nika, Yadda, okay.
All right, I'll check your package weight now.
I'll make sure you sorted that correctly.
All right.
And then, yeah, zero.
Okay, that's good.
All right, someone's getting their Christmas present this
week.
Let's go.
Look at that.
See if you if you get it all correct You're gonna oh
If I never press it Okay, if I never press the button if I
never press the button they'll never don't Okay, congrats.
Okay, I know I
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'll just make sure I never press that button.
It'll be okay.
Okay, D.
That was my medication for my terminal, for my almost
terminal disease, Doki.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
It'll be fine.
Okay, 15.
It'll be 5.
like 0.56 a whiff my second okay that's all right whoops all
right there you go this time I know this is not real all
right so all right let's see by real all way it's got to
prove nice okay there you go David knew he knew things were
not going very well well on this side of the sorting
facility.
Uh...
Alright.
E.
Okay.
Okay, 0 to 30.
I mean...
Yeah.
It is, like, within it.
Okay.
Approved.
There you go.
I'm such a good worker.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, Impland.
We got this.
Okay, the flag seems real.
Alright, E.
Oh my god.
Someone ordered some barbells.
Alright, 28.
Yeah.
Alright, let's print this out.
Look at that.
Someone's gonna buy something.
barbells and then never touch it again.
Oh, I gotta bring the package over.
Like, it has to be on the table.
It's part of regulation, Doki.
You don't understand.
I don't.
I actually don't understand.
It's part of the regulation.
It has to be on the table.
You want to put the stickers on.
Alright.
There you go.
As long as I don't press this button, like, it'll be fine.
No one has to know.
It's just your might be lost in transit forever and that is
okay that's that's okay wait how do I submit contract when
you're ready oh is it here wait did I not do it
how did I not submit it correctly all
right day three just made one oopsie only one oh look at
that profit i made profit guys look at that and i only made
one mistake guys like when you lose your luggage at the
airport um it's not it's not the air it's not the airport's
fault guys it's not the airline well
i don't understand how to activate my contract
too.
That not?
I may as well pay my... Oh, I don't have to pay my biz.
Yeah, it's active.
Submit any two parsers to complete the contract.
How do I submit it?
Where do I go submit my parsers?
Oh my god, there's a basketball hoop!
Wait, I have a back door?
Oh my god, a back door existed oh my god look at all these
doors okay oh my god guys I can play b-ball for real
work harder not smarter no problem mr.
Bezos oh we one day one day I'll be good enough bring your
own basketball the shop has them sorry no but I understand I
understand.
You know, your ex-wife took everything, so I get it.
Press request van?
Where else can I request the van?
I don't understand.
Wait.
How do I submit this to the corporate overlords?
The orange button by the door?
There's an orange button.
button oh was that fragile hourglass okay oh
oh any two parcels okay okay we'll just all right here you
go wait do i have to
all right i assume that it doesn't matter what's in there i
want to keep the approval ones.
It just doesn't, any parcels is fine.
We got the van!
Boom!
Go.
Submit contract.
How do I...
It's in there.
How do I submit it?
Oh, there you go.
Yeah!
What's that?
A 250!
Oh, tier one at the for sale side.
Oh my god, I can buy it.
Oh, my god, Mr. Bates is Don't worry, I'll make sure to meet
the level one employee Shall use my savings to expand the
warehouse Oh my god What do we get here?
If no doors are available Set the parcel inside and check
What?
Okay, this is by air Wait, then what's this?
Oh my god Okay, by air By truck and Mr. Bezos, I know, like,
you know, I don't want to, like, step on any toes or
anything, but, like, this might be, I don't know, I might be
crazy, but, do you think this might be a bit too much work
for one person?
I'm not trying to think for myself, obviously.
Like, I have no free will, but, you know, my arms feel
really, feel a little bit too tired, but I'm not sure, I'm
not sure, though, I'm not sure.
All right, yeah, I can accept.
I'm scared to see you focusing.
Did you just question our almighty Lord and Savior, Mr.
Basis?
They dare question him.
I'm scared to see you focusing on proving company profits by
expanding the warehouse, even at the detriment to your own
sanity.
All right.
check the cargo type delivery schedule all right okay
thursday is my truck and and train now okay that's that's
cool implant like i always like double check the flags okay
yeah the flag is not right reject we gotta make sure i don't
know i don't trust myself but a good worker is not a is not
a smart worker who works at you free to me Terminator.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Justin.
Okay.
Congrati.
Put it on the scale.
What is it?
E.
6.15?
I mean, I guess.
0.30.
And it is within.
Oh my god.
Okay.
There you go.
That's the right sticker.
That's the right one.
I just gotta make sure I didn't fuck that up.
Oh yeah, I can take more contracts.
Destination is Yata.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, only the Yata for the Yata countries.
Okay, buy trade.
Congrati.
Look, I'm still so paranoid that it's not about the flag
situation.
Okay, C is...
the 15.
Oh, yeah, I know.
That's getting denied.
It's a little overweight, ma'am.
You ain't getting that Christmas gift for your daughter.
Sorry, ma'am.
Just a little overweight.
Okay, that's fine.
I can still stockpile this.
Alright, what's this?
Another Congrati?
Oh, developer by plan.
Okay, we don't wait.
Let's see if everything is good.
Congrati?
I just looked at the flag, but let me...
We double check again.
And then E.
Well, if it's E, like...
Okay, as long...
I don't even know if there's a weight above 30.
Okay, yeah, that's fine.
Alright, we gotta put this.
Oh my god, we're streamlining it.
We're so fast now.
Alright, and then...
I'm a good worker.
Store.
Alright.
What's this?
Oh!
Y'all!
Yata, Yata, Nika.
You're real.
Where is it?
Okay, there's that.
Evie, oh, it's cat food!
Let's go!
Don't worry, sir.
Your cat's gonna get the only food that he eats.
12.69.
Nice.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I was gonna say it.
If it was a the not package right after i said that that
would be a little awkward that would be what's my contract
again all right what's that rail cargo is this rail cargo oh
it is
thank you for the rating thank you i got a good stream all
right get in there all right some cat needs their food stat
all right amazon essential brand cat food okay prune prunia
all right prunia that's the right flag and then i'll make
sure the weight is correct it is i'm such a good employee oh
my god doing it guys boom oh more packages okay maula land
they're real right yeah Mawland.
Okay, E.
Guys, what's the word?
Oh, 23.
Why didn't the music stop?
Oh, okay.
That got word.
I don't know if you heard that, but it made a loud, boom,
sound.
And I'm like...
Who's there?
I thought I was going to turn into a fucking horror game
just now.
Yeah, yeah.
And then it got quiet.
I was just like, who's there?
Okay, that was my...
It was like the signal that it's break time.
Hey, boy.
Oh, sorry.
You're not getting your Christmas present.
No, Timmy's not getting their Christmas present.
What's the word called when you're like...
It's super stream.
It's a super stream line now.
Look at that.
I got the system down.
Down to the T.
John Nestia.
My truck.
Okay.
That is a fucking big-ass boss for weight A.
Yeah, optimize.
It's all optimized now.
I got it set to the T.
He's gonna be so proud of me.
Guys, I'm gonna get my bonus.
I'm gonna get a one cent raise, guys.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, shit.
There you go.
Oh, God.
I can smell that high raise coming.
Yay!
Oh, conveyor belts.
Oh, my God.
I forgot about that.
Multiple deliveries at once with a pallet.
Okay, we don't need to buy a pallet.
Okay, we gotta get...
A serial number.
Oh, okay.
Serial number, scanner, straight conveyor.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's buy a conveyor belt.
321.
Let's buy two conveyor belts.
It's okay.
We have...
We have two conveyor belts.
What do I do from here?
I guess not.
For the airport?
I don't know why Why don't I do this Pick up Okay And then
And where's my...
Oh yeah The other one's right here Oh you're right Maybe
he'll give me one bath Maybe he'll give He'll extend my Five
second break To To like Six seconds guys Oh my god Do you
think I'm...
Do you think I deserve it?
Do you think I deserve it, guys?
Is that a fun?
Excuse me, I'm trying to...
There you go.
Okay, that's asking a little too much.
Alright.
Yeah!
Just about to be able to afford a third conveyor belt!
Oh, that's a lot of money.
gone.
Wait, when did I spend $750?
What the fuck?
I forgot to save for a bill.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's okay.
Wait, is it going the other way?
No, they're all going the right.
Oh.
Okay, give me a sec.
I just realized.
Okay.
I was like, wait, what are you talking about?
It's going the right way.
Oh yeah, I bought the expansion Okay, well now we know Okay,
now Well, we know that it's supposed to Okay, there you go
Now it works Now it works, guys
Look, it's my first day It's my first day Alright, here we
go Okay, Vo Kua.
Uh, Vo Kua.
Oh yeah, no, we don't do by tram, sorry sir.
That's not an- we don't have that service.
Now yeah, maybe in like- oh shit, okay.
Maybe in five more years when the robot uprising comes.
It's building up.
I have to eventually submit that.
all right oh wait yacht yacht done yacht done nika that's
correct is it d that is 20 kg oh nice we just made it that's
another parcel there you go in the truck truck time wait
what the fuck where's my Okay, it's still in there.
It's still in there.
Wait, I gotta make sure.
Yeah, that's the right one.
Alright.
We need one more.
One more.
We should be good to go.
Okay.
Implanned.
By truck.
The right flag.
What's the D?
Okay.
45.
Oh, sorry, bro.
We gotta reject that.
Should I pay it extra?
Your first baby's not gonna have a first...
Not gonna have their first Christmas present.
Goodbye.
Burning that...
We're gonna burn that package specifically, too.
Oh, nice.
Prove of...
And rejection.
I didn't check the...
I didn't check whether it's played.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh shit, okay.
That won't be a problem.
I'm just gonna send this out, hoping that that's not my
plane.
Okay, thank God.
I was like, oh, that's my plane.
That's unfortunate.
The Vokua.
I keep forgetting what the country flags look like.
This is a problem.
Okay.
It's okay, we were gonna burn that package anyway.
I put 9.3.
Okay, see, this guy was willing to pay extra.
He was willing to pay extra, even though he didn't need it.
Is there any already approved ones?
Okay, congrati.
I feel like it's just harder to memorize, like, countries
that aren't real.
Oh, my God.
down here okay there you go what was it it was d you okay
see see he paid extra too you didn't need to grab you didn't
even pay for the the d weight class but he still did it all
right what is this oh that's all right we haven't had
deliveries from this place in a while oh it's by rocket ship
sorry that's wrong billionaire bro sorry wrong Sir, this is
the wrong billionaire.
We don't offer that yet.
We don't have by rocket ship.
I'm so sorry.
Jordan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank God Doki is on when I'm saying...
I'm glad you've been joining the stream.
Oh, you get better soon.
Alright.
By air.
Seed.
I think that's the right country flag.
Yeah, if the triangle is up, for some reason, Ligbo...
It's the one that I remember for the country flag.
15.
That's 15.
What was this here?
Oh, just 0.5 cage.
Yeah, we were just off.
The 9.
Okay, so this is full now.
Alright.
It's okay.
It's just my one mistake.
Ooh.
It's okay.
It's just two mistakes, guys.
Okay, that one was correct.
Okay, it's okay, guys.
It's just two.
I don't know when the two mistakes came from.
Where the second one came from.
I don't know where the second one came from, okay?
You'll never know.
this south part for it oh incorrect sticker sticker applied
invalid denial parcel was valid for approval we don't know
that parcel was valid we don't we don't know that for real
like how do you know
uh oh i was just learning about that like i paid my bills i
could just afford it oh yeah i was gonna look up the country
too.
South, or...
That seems correct.
Buy a truck.
Alright.
Ooh, this one's heavy, heavy.
18.
Never mind.
He just paid extra.
I don't believe we just do that.
Wait.
Car, truck.
Yeah, we do trucks.
I just got it.
I'm like more paranoid now.
Congrati.
Wait, that's not right.
Yeah.
I've done so many congrats.
I was like, you don't have a star.
It's a circle.
See, I remember congrats.
That wrong flag, sir.
Wrong flag.
Alright, that one's already denied.
It's a freebie.
Alright.
Oh, God, I need another conveyance, bro.
Can't keep going back and forth.
Oh, another freebie.
Let's go!
Good Jeffrey sees all.
He has cameras everywhere, especially in the bathroom,
because we're not supposed to go in there.
The bathrooms are only reserved for Mr. Bezos when he comes
over to inspect.
Stratom.
That seems right.
Oh, wait.
It's my time.
Never mind.
It's still my time.
That's my time travel.
We haven't invented that one yet.
Oh, wait.
Let me...
I can finally buy another computer.
conveyor belt.
Oh, check out.
Johnathia.
Okay, I'll do this one.
Because this one's by a rocky ship.
I can deny it right now.
There you go.
Kobe!
Oh, this one was very heavy.
It's okay.
It's fine dropping it because the guy's not even going to
get his package anyway.
He's not going to get it anyway, so it's fine.
Johnathia.
Okay.
It should be fun.
There's no...
I haven't seen a package that's, like, over here.
You know what?
Every time I see an E one, I'll just print approval.
Oh, wait.
I forgot to check a flag.
I was so confident.
Oh, I knew.
There's a reason to be confident, because it was correct.
And this one is...
Prunia.
Okay, Prunia.
I remember Prunia.
Yeah, that's a Prunia fat flag right there.
Okay, C.
Prunia.
Yeah, no fragile icon, too.
6.26.
Wait.
Yeah, that's fine.
Print approval!
Boom!
Oh, go up!
Okay.
You're going to get your Christmas present.
Kylo.
Kylo, don't worry.
Don't worry.
Yeah!
We did it, Kylo.
Let's go.
Let's hope there's nothing fragile in there.
Into the square hole you go.
Alright.
My present.
This is the most accurate part so far.
Alright, nice.
I got this one, too.
Yeah.
There we go.
Yeah!
Oh, a serial number keypad.
What do I need that for?
Paste it.
What do I do with it?
Oh, I need the license for it?
Am I licensed?
Yeah, but I have it right here.
Where do I put this?
You'll need to key in Sierra numbers.
What?
Why?
What's the point?
Guys, it's not boobs.
Oh!
They confirm their validity now?
Oh my god, but I do get paid more this time.
I'm a new email.
What's the parcel inspector's favorite herb?
Parsley.
Well done for being proactive in purchasing.
It's nice to finally get the cares about making their boss
more money.
Of course, sir!
For an extra delivery, check parcel seal.
Oh my god.
Okay, yes, I'm the one man army, sir.
Okay.
It's five.
It's day five.
Look at that in five days.
In five days.
Guys, I'm getting promoted.
I mean, I get paid five dollars more,
but...
Look at that.
I got a promotion.
I've noticed you aren't accepting new parcel types.
into the warehouse new parcel types grants more income for
each valid parcel helping our shareholders make more money
that's so great sir that really is a happy board is a good
company happy board will make happy employees they know
what's great for me go to the parcel type tab in your
inspection tablet to learn more okay
That's all right.
The shareholders know what the people want?
Yay!
Okay, $500.
I need a warehouse tier two.
Okay, how much is tier two?
Okay, it's okay.
I guess I can start taking the big boxes.
I can do that.
i think i love the shareholders okay are there any freebies
okay where are the cereal oh okay let's do the okay let's do
the cereal okay do the cereal number first eight five three
six seven zero four zero zero eight five three okay it's
invalid so because it's invalid then it should be it should
be denied i gotta make sure i'm doing this correct okay i'm
gonna oh they did not care about that one box sorry your
package will forever be lost in transit it's nice to see the
duchess showing us peasants how blue collar work is done.
Doki is truly the yeah, I'm for the people guys.
Look at me go.
Alright.
Just like you guys.
4-8-1-9-2.
Why are they all invalid?
Oh, it's because it's my fault.
But I too.
Guys, this is why the robot's gonna take over, guys.
There's a lot of human error going on here.
All right, this should be fine.
There you go.
Approves.
Nope.
Oh, they're not accepting it today.
All right, there you go.
People, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I feel like I have to do zero number first.
Wait, is that real?
That looks like a...
Okay, no, that's not a real flag.
Wait, actually, I'll do country flag first, because I was
like, that does not look like...
Yeah, I was gonna say, congrats flag is a fucking...
Circle.
That's, like, the only flag I've processed.
Oh, gosh.
Like, not again.
Alright.
Oh, hey, look.
It's a tiny one.
It's an envelope.
Oh, it's for Yacht Tanika, too.
We actually need that for the last contract.
Alright.
Please.
Okay.
1.5-1.
nice okay it's valid we gotta put you on the scale god i
need a fucking scanner i gotta make 500 dollars 19.75 oh
please be at the god damn it why did you why did you cheapen
out you're not gonna know if you're accepted in college
deny you'll never know if you got your acceptance letter
now.
Alright, here you go.
Your parents fucked up.
You're right.
Maybe I should place this closer.
Alright.
Open.
There we go.
My career!
Alright.
Let's see.
7, 7, 7, 8, 2, 3, 4, 2, 4.
Okay, it's valid.
And then I know, because it's E-weight, so they...
So this should be fine.
We'll get a story of this.
There you go.
Yeah, they're never, yeah, that's right.
You'll never know if you got accepted or not.
Oh, it's a knight.
That's good.
I don't have to worry about this.
letters on.
It's like those like super exclusive universities where they
don't even, you can't even check online because they want to
be real.
They want to be authentic.
Is that a C?
Do I have a C on my keyboard?
What the fuck?
That is not a number, right?
I just, I just want to be sure, but they add the letter C
into it because I'm not, I didn't, checked social media
today.
I just want to be sure if they added the letter C into the
number system, you know?
Oh my god, I fucked up.
My keypad is underneath the table now.
I gotta fix this.
Okay.
New number just dropped.
I want to know if they, like, it's like how they
recategorize, like Pluto to me, not a it and then like did
they like recategorize the letter c to be a number it just
felt right you know i think yeah it's just i just want to be
sure if they recategorized it or not
okay i'm still trying to find like eight seven eight one
eight four three five eight four Okay, it's valid.
Well, okay, it's E, so it's like the heaviest one.
All right.
Oh, we finally finished the contract, though.
Ooh.
Let's go.
All right.
Submit!
Wait, it was two?
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, that's...
That's a... That's awkward.
Let's see, we're at the 25.
It's fine.
It's... It's fine.
It's a little awkward.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Okay, there you go.
Uh...
Where's your serial number?
look everyone makes mistakes we're only human
that's it that's the that's the company's fault for not
hiring AI take our jobs 17.9
that's oh here should be fine
not hiring the robots we're almost oh I could get $25.
Oh, you're right.
It's my.
Never blame the company.
The company knows what's best for me.
All right.
I got my $25 at least.
Contracts.
Three.
Doesn't matter, but they must be going by rail.
Okay.
That's fine.
All right.
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh, rail is not accepted.
now okay prunia prunia is correct right yeah it is okay
serial number tab
608 903 68 oh wait we're missing a number all right number
god we still have two more
oh soon guys i'm almost at 500 dollars get.
Wait, what did I spend money on?
How did I $13?
Wait, what?
Where's my money?
How do I have $13?
I made 25.
Where did my money go?
Just Rod me.
Did I just got Rod?
I swore I made like I had money oh I had minus 12 what the
fuck happened to my money I have minus 12 oh fuck I put
another sticker on top I just realized it's by cargo okay
you think that worked okay this package is gonna be lost in
it forever it's so unfortunate i guess we'll never know what
happened to that package i guess we'll never know sorry sir
i know i know on the tracking number um you've been waiting
for this package for uh three months but sir it's still in
transit we can't we are it's out of our Sir, it's been in
transit.
There's nothing we can do when it's in transit, sir.
Oh, it's back here.
Sure, just call the helpline.
The helpline can help you.
That's what helpline's for.
Oh, I have nothing there.
Alright, everything seems good to go.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
I didn't send it out So it's fine
Yeah Yeah yeah the terrorists got it Sir They're still
inspecting it Oh I reached day seven Oh my first week I did
it!
I worked the whole Week and didn't get fired yet Oh my god
I'm such a good worker
Alright I'm doing it Is it airplane time?
No, it's only truck time.
Trucks only.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, that's by cargo.
My god, there's so many misprints here.
So we do not do cargo yet.
Alright.
Yay!
Oh, approved.
Oh, by plane.
too.
We'll store this right here until it's time.
Oh, it's this.
Oh, by truck.
Okay, that seems correct.
Let's look at the code.
382-624-672.
Oh, everything looks correct, sir.
Happy holidays.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Okay, happy holiday!
Wait, is it by truck?
Happy holiday!
I'm paranoid.
I have to make sure everything is okay.
Oh, rail!
We need rail.
3, 9, 8, 8, 2, 8, 3, 5.
What?
3, 9, 8, 8, 2, 8, 3, 5, 2.
Okay.
What was it?
Okay, it's on E.
Okay, Jonathan.
Yeah, it's been a while since I saw your flag.
I want to make sure if you're still independent.
All right, nice.
All right.
Prove.
Yeah, I need three of these for the truck.
All right, this time.
This time I can count now.
Three by rail.
All right.
Oh.
Okay, there you go.
Hello.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Doki's on Prime.
Doki Speed at Doki Value for Doki Quality.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Hey, okay.
Let's do the wait first.
Wait, is this Congrati?
It is.
Okay.
Zero point.
Aw.
God damn it.
Why are you guys all so cheap for the holidays?
Now, now you're, now your children are gonna be sad.
It's not my fault.
I'm just doing my job.
You guys didn't buy the right weight class.
Now your children will be sad.
And.
4, 6, 8, 0, 4, 4, 9, 9, 2.
Okay, it's valid.
Just gotta wait this.
Wait, this.
Okay, 0 to 20.
Alright, nice.
Proof!
Wait, is this by truck?
Okay, nice.
By truck, too.
and it goes boom oh hey nice he's got fruit okay bye god
damn it it's fucking what day is it it's sunday we don't do
that on sunday david hold it in your facility wait until
it's tuesday deny oh we have two denials let's go free money
that's for the orphanage well maybe if the oh
It's not karma It's not karma guys I swear to God Also thank
you for the ring Another package lost in transit What a
shame What a shame Oh yeah That is another approved
Okay, by plane.
Okay, I'll check the serial code.
Uh...
What the fuck is the serial code?
There it is.
Okay, 716801024.
Okay, it's valid.
All right, everything looks good, sir.
I'm playing, though.
So, we're stockpiling a lot of them.
Okay.
Jay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Damn, Joki, I just bought something from your merch site and
got the shipping notification within two hours.
Is this similar to how you train your employees?
Respect, dude.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right.
We're making our shareholders happy, guys.
We're making them so happy.
Yeah.
All right, I'll check the super chat.
Serial code.
Oh my god, keep fucking...
I keep fucking bringing up my tablet.
Okay, they're missing two digits.
God, I need like one more rail.
Rail parcel.
Yeah.
That makes so much money, though.
Yeah, none of it.
Let's check the...
Is that the right flag?
I haven't seen a Southport flag.
Deliver in a while Okay Three four One one two Oh hey it's
valid Nice Print approval Boom Alright Jesus there's so many
I still have to wait Tuesday for this too That's the worst
part Alright Uh Any pre-approved shit Anything by rail Nice
There you
uh okay this could be this could be big money right here
five four six zero five two oh five two this is a huge
payday nice yeah this is huge payday time all right we got
three we got two okay i need one more i need Okay, okay,
we...
All right.
It's okay.
Oh, did I drop a real one in the...
Oh, okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's just one mistake.
I actually shipped one out.
Yeah, I just realized.
Oh, it's okay.
The boss won't know.
There were so many packages going out.
I don't think he knows, guys.
That's valid.
Is that by car?
Yeah.
But he'll see, like, all the successful deliveries I did,
though.
And then he won't pay attention to the ones I fucked up on.
Oh, did I weigh it?
It should be fine.
It was an E sticker, right?
Okay, let's weigh this.
It was an e-sticker, right?
Alright, guys.
Okay, this is denied.
Okay, good.
Alright.
See, everything is okay.
See, it's just one...
See, look, it's just one mistake.
It should be okay.
Oh, wait.
There's another one.
Oh, there you go.
Huge payday.
Right here.
There's no letters in my serial code.
nine three six four eight and it's valid and that's that's
the right country all right here we go got it we got the
park packages boom oh shit boom boom three booms yeah yeah
300 oh my god i can afford tier two a thousand dollars in my
savings i can't wait to spend it on the company i can't wait
what oh wait that's the no i i knew i knew how i fucked up
for that that one was the okay we're good of the company
valid oh wait i did not see buy burger my god yeah exactly
i'm just growing the economy i forgot that i did see that
buy burger delivery
so you're not when is rail okay rail is tomorrow i'll just
get do this first
okay okay 2.03 jesus christ what the fuck is in here
740 767 936 all right nice print approval oh my god yeah oh
oh oh here because it's by real all right wait i should be
able to afford it i got six packages in here oh my god get
up Yay!
I unlocked, oh my god, what did I unlock?
Oh, I unlocked the basketball hoop.
Oh, I can, oh my god, in $200, I can have a scanner.
Who needs to pay for hospital bills when I can pay for a
scanner?
We're falling, guys.
We're falling.
Day eight.
Give it up for day eight.
Give me a second.
I get taken by a daily cry.
Gotta get my...
Let me
Okay, I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
The light might be gone from my eyes.
Right now.
Day eight!
Let's see.
The fire is gone.
The light is gone.
It only took eight days.
No, it's just tears of joy, right?
Yeah, it's just tears of joy.
Oh, my God, there's so many contracts.
Okay, valid.
Okay, that's fine.
I could take that one.
Just one delivery.
Oh, I already have one right here.
Send it over.
Okay.
Another day, another dollar.
Don't please go in.
Okay, nine parcels?
Okay, no, this one just needs two.
All right, two.
Wait, that pays more.
Okay, I'll do Perunia.
That's two.
All right.
Guys, thank you.
Quail, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, be careful.
Well, oh, wait, that's it.
He wants prunier, right?
Yeah.
Be careful.
Pace was my go-hungry.
Thank you for the super chat, Gail.
Thank you.
All right, we got one.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, Miss Bird, I'm checking your weekly performances, and
these numbers aren't good at all.
Wait, I can, sir.
I can change, sir.
Don't, sir.
I can work on it.
I'm sorry.
I know I, I know I took a six-second.
break is that five second break but I just just because like
you know I lost track of time I miscounted one second sir
it's okay I'll do better DLN thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you describe your yes company policy what
reflect on you sir it was for tears of joy it was I swear
it's I was crying because I was so happy to work here and
company sir I was felt like I was so fortunate to be here
today to work for your company all right there we go and
then a prunia there's my land always by rocket ship not
Tuesday yet I have so much money stockpiles in there let's
see get by truck I'll do serial code eight five six three
five four six two four all right and then wait
I should be five 1501 yeah that's fine all right and then
the flag just to be sure is that the people haven't been not
a lot of people live in that country
there we go oh did not easy money oh yeah I didn't cry to
destiny a crying zone you're right sorry I forgot the
accommodations are owned by Lord and lovely saver Mr. Bezos
okay rocket okay rocket crate yeah where's the serial number
oh there it is I'm not supposed to get the Get the crate
dirty with my tears I'm so sorry Mr. Bezos I understand now
I need to go to a designated corner Alright
Alright here we go I think that's good That's two right I
can count it too
Where's the corner Where's the Where's the Where's the
Where's the scanner Where's the scanner
A hard worker makes shareholders happy And it makes a worker
happy too If shareholders are happy, worker happy Gotta
remember the motto Gotta remember the mantra For the
shareholders Thank you, Mr. Bezos What would I do about you?
Okay, how do I use this?
What if I...
I don't understand.
I love my job.
This is dystopia.
Oh my god, do I have to buy?
Where's
the...
That's tier...
How do I use this?
Do I use this?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Beep.
Okay, I get it.
I got it.
I figured it out.
Sorry, I'm a little slow, but I figured it out, sir.
Oh!
Oh, it's valid.
I'm learning.
A pooh.
Stop learning.
I'm doing it.
Okay, bye rail.
Today we take bye rail.
Okay, I have an idea.
Oh my god, I can min- Oh, okay, never mind.
I can't min- Oh my god, I can min-max this!
Wait!
Oh my god!
I- I can min-max this!
max this.
I can make so much money.
Okay, wait.
There was one that was already approved, right?
Oh, there it is.
Buy plate.
God damn it.
Still buy plate.
I'm cooking.
I get it now.
I get it.
I'm learning the forbidden technique.
I'm making my own overtime.
I'm...
Bro, it's not smarter too.
I'm actually have to work even harder Because I have to deal
with packages
I understand now.
Now I'm thinking with parcels
Alright, but that always scares me when he's like, boom
Wait, wait Yeah, oh shit Oh shit
is that how do I know if it's that oh when it's green oh
okay okay I figured it out okay vocua that that seems right
yeah all right okay that that's real uh Proof.
There we go.
Let's see if there's any make-believe deliveries.
Okay, that's by plane.
That's by plane.
This is my plane corner.
By truck.
Oh, we got rail.
Wait, do I have a contract?
Oh, I completed it.
okay congrati 125 for just five packages that's barely okay
that's nine packages okay none of this okay must contain
four must be valid with okay congrati i got congrati yeah
they don't know it's mishandled what are you gonna call
there's no okay there is cameras but mr basel doesn't care
But I just want to know we're not stealing.
Oh, shit.
Did a flip.
The cameras are for if we're stealing.
That's it.
They don't know if they's mishandled.
Maybe the truck was going through some potholes, you know?
Any congratulants?
No.
Just Zigbo.
Okay, we'll put the weight on first.
Zero to 15.
Okay, that's fine.
And then we'll scan it.
Oh.
Okay, that's good.
And then the flag is correct.
And then we got another one.
Oh my god, this is a huge payday.
too.
Oh, I got a huge payday for this one.
Yeah, baby.
A 500.
Oh, nice.
Okay, that just made it.
Alright, scan.
Okay, that's good.
Alright.
Print.
Let's go.
Off you go to a conveyor bed.
Oh, my god.
I'm such a, I'm so good.
I'm actually a pro at this game now.
I'm actually a pro now.
okay oh within the weight requirement oh people are
understanding
okay and it's congrati nice yeah i need four of these we'll
get this i'm gonna get a discount code it's gonna happen
zero to 15 pounds okay nice scan time I got system down and
everything prunia I'm pretty sure that's prunius yeah that
is a prune oh my god look at all these they paid extra by
plane and it's still gonna take longer I think that's the
worst part they all paid extra that have the deliveries by
plane because they thought it was faster.
Little do they know.
We only deliver by plane once a week, apparently.
Oh, my God.
No, I don't think he'll give me free time.
That's asking way too much from Mr. Bezos.
Yoko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Customer service.
My grandmother's ashes should have arrived two months ago,
but they're still in transit.
Can you please provide us your ID number so we can go check
it for you?
Press one if you would like to...
Press one if you'd like to have that translated in French.
Press two if you'd like...
It translated in Spanish.
Press three if you would like to talk to a representative.
You have pressed three.
Please hold.
And it's like seven hour hold.
And then you're going to be on that phone call for seven
hours.
Good luck.
My bone?
When the fuck did they add bone?
Tuesday was plane day.
What the fuck do you mean?
It was always Blaine Day!
When did it not become Blaine Day?
Normal.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Monday is now Boat Day.
Oh, that is approved.
And now it's...
Yeah, keep it up.
Keep up, Doki.
It's now Boat Day.
The planes are on strike right now.
Eh.
Nine.
It's overweight.
Planes are on strike.
They're having to own those CSs right now.
All right.
B.
What the fuck?
Okay, 0 out of 10.
Okay, that's 5.
Okay, it's by burger.
Never mind.
Denied.
You don't do it by burger.
Normal size.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, your work has been phenomenal this month.
I sure appreciate it.
Will be doubling your workload.
Pay increase?
Well, about that.
Do you not love the company, Doki?
If you love the company, you won't need to be paid more to
do what you love.
Oh wait, this is approved.
By train.
I did a flip.
Okay.
D.
That's right, right?
Yeah, that's good.
Oh my god, I finally scanned stuff.
Okay, that's approved.
There we go.
By truck.
Here we go.
Cheese.
the system they're like wow you've been delivering these are
so fast dokey I'm like yeah for the shareholders yeah it's
everything for the shareholders all right the nine hit by
plane okay oh my god my package sorry I just didn't know my
own strength there
Oh, shit.
Wait, is that invalid?
Okay, it is.
But she's gonna die.
Alright.
Down it goes.
More packages.
Whoa!
There's no fragile sticker.
I could do this.
Look, if they didn't want me to throw your packages around,
then why the fuck did you not put a fragile sticker on?
it's not my fault it's on you stickers aren't even those
stickers aren't even that expensive a prunius yeah it is
prunius for that okay we're at it's delivered by box i go
for the three my r5090 not even that you're a ramstick whoa
is this a ramstick i hear is that a thousand dollar a
thousand dollar eight gigabyte ramsticks
there you go you also even they do have the stickers we will
throw them we would choose not to read it
there you go there any con oh there you go we needed a
congrati okay
yep that's real
okay that's another one for the congratulant
I knew how many I need four I need two more I know I have a
package from Amazon when I hear a bang on the door there you
go is there a congratulant here only the for congrats
packages.
I'm not becoming more and more it's becoming more real.
Like the longer I work the process gets too real.
Is there one that's like obviously not a real delivery?
Okay, they're all real.
And the more real it becomes.
All these packages I have out.
I figured out the system, guys.
Oh, it got approved.
Nice.
She's integrating too quickly.
She's becoming self-aware.
Okay.
Alright, that's good.
It's the only one taking out the real...
I wish this had multiplayer, guys.
Imagine!
Share the depression together.
If this had multiplayer.
Now I know why there was a crack in my new monitor.
That was delivered on Monday.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
She's still smiling.
We need to change that.
I'm just going to give her the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I paid the extra.
I have my package delayed, broken, and lost.
Yes, but it's done by Tokey.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's the best part.
Oh my god, I have so many packages out here.
Okay, give me a sec.
All right.
I'm gonna figure this out.
Alright, I'm gonna grab the ones with E.
The ones with E are easier to handle.
Alright.
Bakua.
I've been, like, grabbing packages all the time that I,
like, forgot what the flags looked like.
There's a fragile secret?
No, there wasn't.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Wait, there was one with...
Yes, nice.
Get that out of here.
yeah oh my god come on yeah give me one more package come on
give me one more order come on one more waiting next
delivery come on beat the system no we're so close we got
another one in all right this one's e is that correct all
right scan this by truck approved
All right, which one is also E?
E ones are easy, because I don't have to weigh it.
Oh, there you go.
I have so much, like, here now.
Congrati.
Okay, nice.
Oh, my God, it's back cake.
God damn, it's back.
I didn't even see the cake one.
God, I needed the Congrati one, too.
Guess I'll have to weigh it.
oh my god i'm rich wait i'm so obsessed with oh my god i
actually became a real worker i didn't even realize my money
at this point i i got so into it i didn't even realize i
have the money to buy things now i okay scanner conveyor all
right i still actually never mind i can't even afford it It
still doesn't even matter.
I still can't.
I thought I had a lot of money, but it still didn't matter.
Never mind, guys.
I'm still...
I'm still broke.
Oh, no!
Oh, I got it.
I entered the flow state.
Okay, see.
That's the right flag.
Yeah.
12-foot.
Okay.
Wait.
Did it scan correctly, though?
I just gotta be sure.
Okay.
Gotta make sure.
Alright.
Way time.
C.
Oh.
About to reject this.
Sorry, ma'am.
Not too cheap for Christmas.
About a big ass present.
it doesn't matter you cheaped out on the delivery don't take
only oh wait oh i don't mean to weigh this okay all right
and then it's one day that those colors are gonna flip and
it's gonna fuck with me i wouldn't i won't even notice
they're gonna flip it i can tell Don't worry Yay Oh my god I
can forward it now Okay It's the Scanner conveyor What does
this do?
I did it!
I got a hundred prices!
Oh my god It's time!
I'm airport security now Okay Okay What does this do?
I put it in?
Okay, this is so slow.
Okay, all right.
Okay, that's way too slow.
I can finally be the TSA, guys.
In my inspection, oh, upgrade.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, we got to increase the speed of that.
Speed of deliveries?
Expert size?
Alright.
I mean, the weight's correct at least.
Apparently.
Okay.
Nice.
Wait, lost to...
Lollie-L-L-L-L-L?
What the fuck is lost to L- Okay, yeah, that's not a real
country.
It's not recognized by the United Nations.
I'm sorry.
It was not recognized.
Oh, hey, that's a fragile sticker.
Hey, guys.
This has a fragile sticker, guys.
Look at that.
Hey, everyone.
There's a guy who put fragile sticker on their package,
guys.
basketball
Let's go It's like kick the baby and says kick the box Let's
put it Let's just examine the weight on this
Whoops Wait did I said it was a good weight or no I can't
Wait was the weight good as
it started jingling jangling inside there oh it is okay it's
green all right by put god damn it's always by plane like
this i'm i'm checking to the next day wednesday is plane day
i did enough wednesday is plane day i have a lot of planes
Yeah, I'm pretty sure you can automate it.
I just can't be bothered right now to figure that out.
All right, it's Plain Day!
It's Plain Day!
Oh my god, it's finally...
It's the most wonderful day of the year.
It's Plain Day.
day the most wonderful time of the year there we go oh my
god we reached the end
yay y'all i'm done i quit i quit i just i toughened it out
till plain day it was the only thing that would bring me joy
I worked until it was Play Day before I quit and never came
back.
I literally, after I set up all my packages and Play Day, I
left and never came back.
I didn't even put in a notice.
I didn't even put in a fucking notice.
I just went out the door and it was over.
There is.
Nobody quit to have a son I just went out the door and I
never returned They don't know what happened to me But it
just never came back I'm okay
Mission accomplished I just wanted to be there for playing
day It was the only day that would bring me joy
um um when they give us super chat thank you thank you as
someone who only lasted three weeks in ups center the only
unrealistic part is it's too clean and lacking in conveyor
belts seriously the place was as grimy as a chicken oh my
god thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yeah i
could have had conveyor belts but it came out of my own
paycheck and i was just like i just I was like, I can't be
able to afford my first meal of the week.
Yeah, after plane day, what else is there to look forward
to?
I waited so long for plane day.
Anyway, okay, so unfortunately, I won't be doing a second
stream today.
I forgot to tell about that at the start of the stream
because I'm actually behind a lot of stuff right now um and
also i i did a lot of long streams today oh not today this
week um i did a lot of long streams this week so my voice is
starting to get like a bit scratchy because i did a lot of
uh endurance streams like i mean i fucking did eight hours
of scooby-doo and then also nine hours of 80s um i realized
like oh shit uh when I woke up this morning, my throat felt
super duper dry.
So I was like, oh, I gotta, yeah, I gotta like, I can't do
another, another stream today.
Uh, yeah, well, there's still gonna be a member stream
tomorrow.
I just can't do a double stream later today.
So I'm just gonna let you guys know right now.
I'll tweet about it too.
I'm gonna tweet about it later.
Yeah, I forgot to say it before we, I forgot to say before
we play the game.
I just realized that.
Um, yeah, so we're gonna, I'm going to be working off stream
today.
And also because I have the holiday Matsuri panel with Mint
tomorrow as well.
And a meet and greet on Sunday.
So I was just like, oh, I don't want to overbook myself and
stretch myself too thin.
But don't wait.
Next week, there's going to be a fun Christmas stream next
week.
So I'm planning on something really fun for you guys.
Well, I hope it's going to be fun.
But I'm super excited.
Anyway, guys.
I'm going to call it here.
As always, everybody.
Oh, yeah.
The New Year one is going to be very, very fun.
I'll just say that.
The New Year countdown will be a very fun stream.
A very, so be there or be square.
New Year countdown, PSD time, by the way.
PSD time.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody bye guys bye